we are cheap as a currency so the fact
that it's it's softer but it's not
collapsing I think is quite right
the market is correctly I think assuming
that the fears of that No Deal better
than a bad deal hard brexit have surely
gone and the market is anticipating that
if there is either an extended
transitional arrangement or a much
softer brexit than we looked at last
week then actually there is a floor
under the pound we can look at how
Sterling's traded actually against the
dollar over the last week or so there we
go so that's the big cliff edge at 10
o'clock on Thursday evening actually say
I mean it's there is a bit of a flaw
love hearing there are you reasonably
confident then about this soft brexit
Theory M I'm fairly confident but I have
to put it in the context of despite what
your reporter has just said you can we
really be sure that mrs. may leads us
into the negotiations and concludes the
negotiations
you know the arithmetic of average of
for by-elections a year means this is a
government that may not last the two
years of the negotiations and that I
think is the thing that the markets over
time will begin to worry about right now
you know the economy is okay a little
bit softer but you know no disaster and
the currency I think right now reflects
that but it's more in the medium and
longer-term that I have some concerns
now let's talk briefly about the footsie
we've all talked about those longer
concerns I mean nothing we can show the
footsie here over the last couple of
there we go we're going back a week
there big spike there I mean this is a
almost de binary trade isn't it sterling
falls footsie goes up but is that it's
really that simple and well in the very
short term it's a knee-jerk reaction
very simple as we all know 75% plus of
the footsie 100 earnings come from
outside the UK so simple translation
effect means that found weakness the
shares will rear eight but it is you
know that's a knee-jerk it's more in the
medium-term about you know back to
looking at what the Fed is going to do
this week with interest rates you know
what
the global economy looking light clearly
much better news from Europe you know
the US data is still a bit mixed we've
got this curious situation where the
bond market is more or less siding on
the side of things to get softer and the
equity market is pretty much saying no
things look all right and at some point
in the coming bubbles we've got a result
which one of those is right now looking
at the longer term you've got some real
concerns now about the way the economy
is going to trade over the next few
years over the way companies are going
to be treated by the government yes I do
think this is a very significant part of
a turning points this election because
it really brought home you know for 20
years now we've had a growing wealth
disparity in in the country between the
older and the younger so for the first
time in living memory or for longer the
younger generations can actually not
look forward to being better off than
their parents and the previous
generations and I think they've they've
stood up and voted for a different type
of government most of them were not
around during the 70s to know what some
of the issues around socialist
government were and they are the high
inflation that was around at the time
and to them the Corbin proposition looks
really pretty appealing so I think both
conservatives and the Labour Party but
clearly the Conservative government has
really got to start to put in place
policies that will address this
disparity of wealth and income between
the older and the younger generation and
that's going to mean capital losing ads
at the expense of labor but I think as
part of this huge shift we had in 79
everything was going away from labour in
favour of capital it started going a
little bit the other way with Osborne's
introducing a minimum wage and I think
this will continue really quite
aggressively in the coming years and it
has to labour has had too little of the
cake capital has been I think in the
ascendancy to an excess and I think you
know whole range of policies whether
it's you know don't anticipate further
cuts in corporation tax will there be
more analysis of things like share
buybacks
so on